hey guys this is the Reuben report I'm
still Dave Rubin and I have two of my
favorite most enlightened guests Kelly
Carlin Rick Overton how about that
enlightened I had a Stewart Lee for
enlightenment I don't know I want
someone shademan today all right take my
word for it these are very enlightened
guests so let's get right to it got to
start with racism because that is the
big topic of the week you thought we
kicked it in America but no Donald
sterling we now all know what happened
so let's just fast forward and go to
what happened yesterday which was Adam
silver the new NBA commissioner laying
down the hammer let's go to the video
game I am banning mr. sterling for life
from any association with the Clippers
organization or the NBA mr. sterling may
not attend any NBA games or practices he
may not be present at any Clippers
facility and he may not participate in
any business or player personnel
decisions involving the team he will
also be barred from attending NBA Board
of Governors meetings or participating
in any other league activity I am also
finding mr. sterling 2.5 million dollars
the maximum amount allowed under the NBA
constitution okay so if you were hiding
under a rock 10 second recap Donald
sterling owner of the Clippers 9 minute
audiotape incredibly racist while
talking to his black and Mexican
girlfriend we'll get to that part in
just a second I mean there's so many
layers of this let's just start with
just broad racism it's it hasn't gone
anywhere has it no Isis Abama got
elected I think it's pretty much kind of
in the closet so did we have a little
dip when Obama came in was there a
little dip and a feeling like maybe
we're getting past this and we're
post-racial and now it's starting to
it's ugly head again do you think that's
what's gonna know yeah I think we for 10
seconds when Obama got well Bhama got
elected that was pretty that was amazing
but I mean the fact that the guy was
black and had this weird name I thought
there's no way America is going for this
and they did it was great
but yeah it then it just pushed all the
buttons and all of the fear of the white
males who are losing the battle sorry
guys
yeah it's it's now it's now seeping out
of every corner of our culture so his
weird name are you saying that's why
they always say Barack Hussein Obama do
that
Rick racism did but I thought we were
past it but I guess not huh well shows
you how smarter racist is - hey I'm in
charge of a hey I'm done I'm in charge
of a whole team all right come on down
to my Ford dealership but unless you're
Asian pull them out of there hey come on
down to the bathhouse unless you're gay
this guy he's not a very bright guy he
wasn't destined to be anything but
briefly lucky yeah we do you guys feel
slightly different if he didn't have
this crazy history of racism you know
Elgin Baylor the former GM of the
Clippers had gotten into him got into
some stuff with him there's been this
slumlord issue that he didn't want black
and Hispanic people renting his
apartments if this had been somebody
that had a perfectly clean record as far
as we knew would you feel different
about a private phone call absolutely
and there is an issue around the privacy
of that phone calling cream abdul-jabbar
wrote a great little piece I think for
Time magazine online and he talked about
that part of it that he didn't like that
part of it but yeah it might have been
like a Michael Richards moment or
something for Donald sterling I mean who
knows but the point that creme
abdul-jabbar made and these other people
is that this guy's been doing this for
years and years
he's known he has a reputation in the
city for being like this and no one made
a fuss about it then so but it takes
something like this you know a TMZ
moment in agriculture to actually push
to push him over the edge this new media
we have that you know they're
discounting as oh that's just the
alternate media
that's just citizen journalism has
having gargantuan sledgehammer impact on
circumstances there was the kid who had
Alzheimer's in school was being bullied
so even Asperger's as Berger said he was
in school and he records the the bullies
and they sue him and so the the mass
media took over and they dropped the
suit and they ran and hid yeah and
there's some other circumstances like
that aren't there it's powerful but it
is also there's an issue I mean you know
this was a private phone call and I
guess the girlfriend today and when the
in the LA Times the girlfriend was
saying that she did not mean for this to
go out and she did not release it but
there was a third party involved we
don't know who that is yet who did
release it so do you guys fear that that
the privacy thing I mean we talked about
privacy at some level every week on they
shown we're gonna do more of it in a
little bit but that the privacy thing
has completely disappeared because we've
all said things privately in private
conversations we're all in the comedy
world where you joke about things that
you do it publicly and it can be taken
the wrong way much less so if you did it
privately so do you worry about that
that we're losing that at all which in
no way is a defense of anything he said
on in that audiotape obviously I don't
think that we're yeah and we're talking
about two different things I'm afraid of
losing other kinds of things over that
system entirely than just I said the
wrong thing in a joke I think we may
have given up more freedom than that for
this artificial safety in that system I
don't I'm not sure if there's any real
safety at all and and what they provide
us with this security system I don't
think America well I don't think they're
even referring at all to our individual
safety when they're recording they're
wondering when we're gonna wise up and
come out do something I think in general
though I don't think we've really had
the privacy conversation yet I think
we're all experimenting with this stuff
and I mean look at social media we we
give away all of our privacy in order to
connect to people on Facebook and
Twitter in all those places you know you
sign it away when you when use you
download the app and so we I don't think
we've really even begun to have a real
conversation about I don't think I don't
think the average person it's hid their
life yet yeah and when that does then
the conversation will really start over
we're trying to do it here
why I bring it up every week do you guys
to me it seems like the NBA did
absolutely the right thing Adam Silver
brand new guy you know David Stern
somewhere in July of it or not they did
the right thing you know for publicity
because of obviously this has been going
on before and they knew about it before
it was okay before until this form of
media got hold of it and aimed it like a
set of guns on him and they recognized
that we have a set of controls to shoot
at them with words and they're terrified
of these words and they even said that
they they've been wanting to take action
against him for a while but they had
they watch these lawsuits go down and
the lawsuits kept going down in his
favor so they really couldn't make the
move and my understanding is if he
hadn't done what he did yesterday every
single team was gonna walk off the court
last night yeah which would be really
fun even if they just delayed the games
a half hour and of the TNT ESPN
it was the advertisers that motivated
most of this you know board members long
oak table the pounding fists you know
did you guys see the the video of the
advertisers at Staples Center they were
literally covering up advertisers their
billboards with the Virgin America seats
were going away what kind of racist has
a black girlfriend we've been talking a
lot about this on The Young Turks yeah
so what's going on there with that
mentality that you could have a black
girlfriend and then you could say to
this girl
do not bring black magic Johnson look at
the racist part if you know any if you
care at all about basketballs you would
want to be associated with he's an
amazing guy yeah how do you how do you
guys parse that level of race well you
know that that kind of racism in general
is fear of the other it's a it's a it's
your unconscious psyche afraid of the
thing the unknown the thing that you
can't control and the thing that that is
so different from you that you can't
recognize it
and it leaks out in personalities in all
sorts of interesting ways so having a
black or Latino girlfriend you can [ __ ]
her you know so you can have control
over her you can sexually dominate her
that's one way to deal with the other
the unknown and the other is then to try
to control you know your public space
and here's a man clearly a ton of money
you look at the LA Times ads this guy
takes out once a month you know touting
him oh I've got another award with this
or whatever total narcissist he wants to
control his kingdom and that's one way
another way of dealing with it I'm going
to control my space and you get to come
in and you don't I mean it's it's it's
actually not as strange as it looks
yeah is it also sort of that plantation
mentality like you know we can have the
the black girl in the house and I don't
have to show any love yep she's just a
UT latina baby yeah no I think that's a
great analogy for sure yeah
actually last question on this do you
think the NBA should force him to sell
because that's the one thing they
haven't done at this point and there are
some questions as far as legality
because they're their bylaws are in
public so you know maybe the owners
would have to vote on it do you think
they should force it just to really put
the final stamp on this no I guess so I
don't know much about that world but
what is he gonna do what choice does he
really have wears not welcome yeah can't
show up to the games anyway so you can't
do anything what's the point all right
well hopefully he sells okay let's move
on I thought this was fascinating there
is a new study released by the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences claiming that one in 25 of
people that are sentenced to death are
actually innocent that's 4% so from 1973
to 2004 1.6 percent of those sentenced
to death in the u.s. 138 prisoners were
exonerated and released because of
innocence death sentences account for
12% of known exonerations of innocent
people from 1989 to 2012 the study
concluded that the criminal justice
system goes to far greater lengths to
avoid executing innocent defendants than
to prevent them from remaining in prison
indefinitely okay so there's a lot of
stuff here so again I want to start with
the broad thing where do you guys stand
on capital punishment I have a feeling I
know
but perhaps I don't recommend let you
take this one first I believe you have
the right in the moment to defend
yourself like two animals and in that
split second if I gotta do is something
terrible so I stop something terrible I
have to do it but later as an act of
revenge I don't know you know and there
are the dodgy cases they so evil there's
no fixing them the problem with it is it
opens the gate to a system that goes yes
take the one bad guy and five normal
good ones too and I'll take some of
these now and then I'll privatize and
just start hoarding to kill netting
people in to keep my lights on yeah
which is what we're doing the privatized
prison thing which is a whole other time
it's a topic but it's the same mentality
of seek the reason for yeah you built it
now look for a reason to use it yeah
it's it's it's it's it's like the
marijuana laws there's no logic there's
no rationality around the stuff it's
it's pure emotion you know the drug laws
are all based on you know wanting to
control populations through that and
this is the same thing there's no actual
proof of anything that this reduces
crime the people who are enforce the you
know law and order people who actually
work in law and order are against it
because they know it doesn't reduce
crime it costs more to have it it's it's
the most irrational system possible and
I don't want the state in charge of
deciding who's with this new study this
means that there's a good percentage of
people who are definitely innocent and
are being put to death yeah so I really
for years before that yeah they're
mostly dead in here like half of them
you know their spirits gone and it's
just a shell by the time you kill their
you know right being look being put in
jail for life isn't that much better
obviously but at least you're breathing
so it's a little bit better I totally
agree and it is cheaper which also makes
no sense butch that's another thing
about our legal system that should be
you know if those other people up for
death row from Wall Street I might have
China's got it all worked out with
industrial statistic that California
would save 1 billion dollars over five
years by replacing the death penalty
with permanent imprisonment all right so
that being said so if you take that so
if you take the financial angle and you
take the 4% which is a big number it is
do you think there's any number that
would flip the the people that are for
the death penalty is there any number if
that got up to 10% because I don't think
they would change their mind I don't
think there's any empirical evidence
that would cause them to change their
money I think people who believe that an
eye for an eye is right is this just the
way they believe and they don't care how
many innocent people have to be I guess
not Superman the new collateral damage
Superman he's mad that some guy knocked
his mom over so he goes through three
apartment buildings you know blows one
end and out the other with my kids
cradle and you know whatever you did
something to me personally and this is
person crash bang and that kind of many
people do you think Superman killed I
just watch it did you just see the
building's you went through October
buildings corn silos were ruining life
that the shot the farmer whose corns on
the ball I'm sorry Betsy Mad campaign
mentality that mentality is the same
thing as I am you know we are doing this
for your own good lotta you got to die
for your own good a lot of the innocents
have to do it to protect you it's
becoming evident it's a broken system in
thinking and as we know the culture wars
right now is Old Testament versus
rational science people that's where we
are in America for 30 years and it's
it's heating up now and but it just it
does it becomes so obvious you know when
you look at just the numbers and then
today last night of course in Oklahoma
yeah
horrific horrific they went to execute
this man and they've got new medicine
and he woke up and he was twitching and
everything and then brought a heart
attack 40 minutes later really like do
we think that maybe that qualifies as
cruel and unusual
and you know what if the death penalty
was so good maybe they wouldn't have to
do the thing where the people that all
press the button at once so you don't
know who actually did it or the firing
squads right where some of the people
have blanks because they don't want to
live with so if it was really okay you
it seems like you'd be able to find more
people willing to actually kill them
right yeah no it's it's and then the
fact that she's she's not stopping
executions in her state they're just
gonna wait two weeks and try to sort
this out yeah cuz that should probably
what do we do what do we do to reform
some of these people cuz yeah there are
the people maybe the Hannibal Lecter's
you know that really can't be reformed
or ever put back into society but we
have a plenty of people that go to jail
for life or go to jail for half their
lives that that can be reformed and it
seems like we make people more hardened
criminals then actually help us the
institutional is what happens in those
walls of those prisons changes people
they go from humans to animals I was
just watching a frontline the other
night about solitary confinement and it
it dehumanizes these people to the point
where I can't imagine them ever
functioning outside those walls again I
don't know what the answer is it's it is
you know that's a form of torture yeah
do what they do to Americans a lot of
torture stuffs happening to Americans
all the time yeah a lot more and more
and more of it like against all treaties
everywhere let's move on let's talk
about the environment I thought this was
really fascinating if you don't think
we're altering the climate you're not
big on climate change maybe a little
more evidence will prove it to you
so there has been a major major drought
they're saying one of the biggest if not
the biggest droughts ever in California
is happening right now and workers in
Northern California right now are
engaged in this massive mission to move
25 million baby salmon from five inland
hatcheries to the ocean so that they can
breed and live lives and grow
we've got some photos so this is they're
just moving them I mean they're moving
there's a lot of salmon in those trunks
there's a lot of omega threes in those
trucks yeah that's right we've got one
of the salmon flowing through a pipe so
then they pipe there literally piping
them in so we're taking them from a
trees because they will die where they
are because of the drought and now we're
pumping up the ocean and we've got one
more
this is them being released into the
Pacific okay so so ammonia slee
deposited watching one of those
artificial insemination put it in the
ocean and then per splash that's right
yeah are we totally look I make I know
I'm making a bit of a jump I don't have
any empirical evidence that says this is
absolutely climate change yeah all of
our environment stories I could just at
the ambulators know but really look we
don't have any evidence that this
specifically is because of something
that humans have done to the environment
but we keep hearing more and more about
these stories and species that are going
extinct and and climates that are
changing and changing topography and all
this stuff
are we just gonna just simply destroy
this earth the earth is pretty resilient
considering meteorites of hills and
stuff like that some little a little
more we personally our phase may be done
the phase of this form of biped may be
done I think something's gonna come up
and make it the numbers the numbers may
be done definitely large we may get rid
back a bunch this this whatever this is
we I mean unless they come up with some
super neato thing that can reverse all
of this real quick the scientists have
decided that yeah we're we're already on
the slippery slope downhill bars let's
[ __ ] Mars up now but the whole point of
going there to [ __ ] it up [ __ ] it up
gets gets all about getting the iron and
the war out of it but that's the thing
about this fishery thing which is you
know I guess part of it was that they
can't if they let them go their normal
route there's not enough rivers and
streams and they're going to take a left
turn instead of a right
at some point or whatever but anyway
aren't these salmon aren't these the
fish that are born and then they go down
their little saying and they go out in
the ocean and they live a life and they
go hey I need to make babies and they
turn around and they go back up the how
are they gonna do that part so that's a
little confusing to go to the coastline
and wait for their truck to show
semi-truck now father that's actually
really funny like they get dropped off
in the ocean it actually changes
everything that they concerned about
this part we need to speak to a
scientist all right so we're not
scientists and I know we're gonna have
some scientist yelling in the YouTube
thing but if you want to what there's an
amazing documentary I think it might be
on YouTube somewhere about the life of a
salmon and if you want to know why
salmon are so healthy for us to eat just
watch the documentary because you their
whole life is going swimming upstream
and you can see how they're building
their muscles and it then it becomes
rich with omega-3s and the fatty acids
that we need so we're really screwing up
some seriously the thing - I when I read
the whole article about this is that you
know the reason we're doing this okay
yeah for the salmon and everything no
not really it's so that we can have
locks on the East Coast the bagel lobby
and you're depositing them into Pacific
which is now radioactive so it's gonna
be locked Scylla we talked about
Fukushima a couple weeks ago they're
they're safe FEMA yeah exactly they're
saying that it's not that the levels are
you know not going to affect humans but
who knows that's one of these 20 years
it might but and here's my other thing
too we're spending all this money to
take up these sweet little fishies and
drive them I think wouldn't be nice to
use that money to actually fix them
though the the issues we've got maybe
like some alternative energy we you know
it's just so that's the part that that
always fascinates me Goldberger
yes so that's the part that always gets
me because the people that say well
we're not doing you know climate change
isn't actually happening they seem to be
the people that are more interested in
money but it seems to me there's also a
lot of money that could be made and
going green and you wouldn't be hurting
anyone so that's the disconnect that I
don't understand
yeah it's always the yeah but I got this
stuff already put in yeah yeah we got
the oil pump they I don't wanna have to
pull every oil pump out with so much I
want to get to the wind when we've
tapped the oil not when it's this much
and I gave up this much money to start
all over again and slowly build a new
market as opposed to rock and roll this
one I guarantee you you know these these
big oil companies they do these 10 years
scenario things they're they're looking
at this stuff they they get where
they're gonna have to go because they
want customers and they want to make
money in 10 15 20 years but you're right
they want to you know squeeze every
little bit out before they make the big
turn so that is this just the next step
in evolution that's probably been going
on forever and ever will just get to a
point where we've ravaged this planet so
much that we just have to go somewhere
else I mean that's sort of what space
equation was about right we're gonna
have to go somewhere else and then we'll
probably do it there too I guess that's
what avatar was about I think I just I
believe you just did that yes that was
very good you know while we're this
version of us consuming species we're
pretty much this parasitic predatory
threat to any place we go we put a flag
in we photograph ourselves or anything
but we're already immediately killing
everything around us to set up camp you
know and not that there aren't other
animals there already doing it will be
the absolute best at it wherever we go
top predator wherever we unless we show
up on Mars and then the day we get there
somebody that's a little more advanced
than us also realize that they needed to
get there too and their guns are a
little bigger doesn't work out well for
the humans that's right we make good
pets we will make we will make good pets
me really well all right let's talk
about net neutrality we've been doing a
bunch about it I really beyond the money
in politics thing I think this is the
most important thing going on right now
so the FCC struck down net neutrality it
didn't look like they were gonna do it
but they did net neutrality is the basic
principle that everyone deserves equal
internet access and that the Internet
service providers have to provide the
highway should be equal for everybody
now they flip that so that the companies
can throttle the internet so
you don't think that's important to you
let's say you're someone who watches The
Young Turks there's a chance right if
you're watching this and you believe in
alternate media
well if Time Warner which owns CNN says
well you know we don't like those young
turks because they're not given the
appropriate message well then they can
actually start throttling the speeds
with which you get the Young Turks
videos get these videos so this is
hugely important and especially now in a
time when the mainstream media has
failed us miserably and Cable News is a
disaster and all that so what again
we'll start with the broad thing was the
internet broke and I didn't know it was
there was that really a problem here
that the FCC had to jump in and get
involved it was were you finding that
the internet was broke it was only
broken to the people who were suddenly
losing their power and money that's who
it was broken the rest of us were like
hey look we have more power and access
to our consumers and to our audience
directly now this is amazing this is
like you know the 60s all over again is
that a free love with other people it's
a lot of porn you know that the
front-runner but yeah it was not broken
I just love the way they're couching
this the FCC - they're like trying to
say but as consumers you're gonna be
happy because when you're streaming your
Netflix video there'll be no glitches
because will give Netflix and people
like that priority which you know I get
it at 2:00 a.m. when I'm watching the
bridge I want to you know have it
flowing correctly but yeah this is all
based on the fact that and everyone will
play fair don't worry everyone's going
to be fair about this so you've given me
the perfect segue so we've got a quote
from the FCC chairman he said to be very
direct the proposal would establish that
behavior harmful to consumers or
competition by limiting the openness of
the internet will not be permitted
now that sounds nice and that sort of
sounds like what you were just saying
but it doesn't there's no nothing
there's no teeth in that they're gonna
they just decided to change what was
working and then say well we promised to
not screw it up any further yeah but god
forbid you say [ __ ] you know yeah yeah
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is it you
first we got to get to the voter fraud
because there are four of them through
[ __ ] history and so make sure
everyone has to have an ID so they can't
vote and I'm the same guy that thinks
this is another important law to put it
that's the same exact mindset as that is
an artificial problem to take command
back from people who are getting power
from those other stories we were talking
about earlier that you're changing the
way we make money you came you [ __ ]
with us now we got it we're gonna pull
the law going with a little bit of a
conspiracy theory here could this
possibly be why CNN gave us three months
or whatever it is of 24-hour plain
coverage because they want to keep our
eyes off the real problems because they
are owned by giant corporate
conglomerates that gain access and gain
the money that you're talking about and
we're the ones threatening them of
course you could see it that way but
really CNN once your eyes just to be on
them they don't care what you're
ignoring they just want their I mean
they have the best ratings and what five
years or something like that says a lot
yeah so I know I'm not a I'm not one two
people sitting in a room and you know
making up decisions about this you don't
need a conspiracy theory the system is
already you know against us so yes
that's my personal view do we need what
you've been talking about a couple times
so far do we need this groundswell of
support starting at the bottom people
taking to Twitter Facebook you know the
99% all that - is that the only way we
have a chance to get this thing fixed
when have we not hmm
when has that not been the case when
does that not work yeah it always works
same key same lock every time like works
every time you to put it into it just
you got to look for the key I'm too busy
I got other stuff I got to do someone
will do it someone will hit the lock for
me where's everyone at once it's like
one of those nuclear-missile things or
two people got to put the key in but
it's an everyone key everyone I do
believe that innovation I mean you know
the internet and and everything around
it you know is is all about young minds
innovating with things that we can't
even begin to ponder and I I think
there's going to be some young turk so
we're in the back of a room and he'll be
like I figured out the way to open up a
billion times this over here this space
and we'll all jump in there and the
corporation's would be like but hey why
isn't anyone watching our stuff anymore
and we're all over there you know who
knows I mean they'll jump in and control
them and someone will do it again and
that's the way it is that's the way
innovation works that's the way that's
the way our democracy works that's the
way evolution works
I've been fox rabbit and Fox right yeah
Kelly Carlin you gave me a little hope
at the end of this segment I did not
know that there was hope when you when
it comes to the FCC but apparently there
is okay well speaking of the death of
the Internet let's talk about the death
of humans have you heard about this
poses have you heard about this poses at
funerals dead bodies imposes at funerals
this is the new big thing but don't take
my word for it let's look at the video
the life of the party even though she's
dead friends of New Orleans socialite
Mickey Easter Lane through their pal a
grand old funeral down in the bayou
she looks just like Nikki sitting in a
garden scenery to depict a vacuum the 83
year olds daughter said her mom loved
the limelight loved the attention so
there she was kind of posed with the
help of some extreme embalming yeah
there she is I mean she looks stuffed
and taxidermied and all that good stuff
but if you didn't get enough of a view
of this we got two pictures of other
people that I've been putting poses post
posthumously so the dead guy is the guy
in the hoodie with the sunglasses a
little unclear to me for a second and
the people on the right is his wife and
his girlfriend one more then we'll come
back let's look at this next one look at
this guy huh is he having fun in death
or what wondering did he die on his
motorcycle because that's a little
pretty light helmet he's wearing there
go for more of that kind of stuff yeah
there should be everything everything
that was the moment before you die you
should be posed and it you know the
diorama of death yeah yes I think a
whole Museum of these things yeah right
it's a moment before yes of course oh
there's the guy cleaning the gun the guy
doing the order that something where you
can do iconic ones you know like Johnny
Carson doing his golf swing my dad of
course wanted to be thrown out of a
helicopter and just left wherever he
landed you were a good set yeah I
decided again oh I see what pose what I
choose exactly you'd really what would
you choose here it is okay your camera
your death pose
question mark above always always
um this seems this actually seems kind
of cool to me we don't talk about death
all right we don't we don't sort of that
that the video it was a celebration of
this woman's life they had her doing the
things that she loved yes it's a little
weird I suppose but but other cultures I
mean you know you go to you go to India
and you know people are carrying the
dead-body down to the Ganges and burning
the bodies right there I mean it's an
event a family comes it it's a
celebration it's a you know they're
they're connected with with it I think
it's I think it's a I think it's a step
in the right direction I really do it's
a party we had talked about all the
funny fun stuff the person did so
they're kind of come alive yeah all the
stories and that had drunken sleeves on
anyway and I love the socialite I love
that and she against arranged the whole
thing and had ideas and knew what she
wanted and yeah you know Catania how
soon until we do a little animatronics
with these people - that's the the next
step right all right watch out for the
freaky guy that wanted the love doll
knock it off yeah knock it off
do we need to discuss death more in this
society we've talked about a little bit
on your show and I've done your show and
I feel like it is something that we
don't have a real sort of healing
discussion well I think it underlies a
lot of what drives us in this country
are our consumerism is driven by our
fear of death you know we don't want to
have a quiet moment we don't know how to
sit still and not be putting something
either in our eyeballs or our mouths you
know and and that's that is a fear of
death that's the underlying you know
denial of that that great monster are
always around the corner the the great
unknown the biggest unknown yeah give me
something deep the science is now
projecting that a person can live
in the next half of this century the
wealthy should be able to get the you
know Elysium machine to keep them alive
for a hundred and fifty years exhausting
have you heard about that hundred and
fifty years let me guess springtime sure
pretty [ __ ] sure Oh [ __ ] flour 150
goddamn springtime American Idol eighty
nine I was ready to be killed after
American Idol
alright let's talk about love we're
gonna end on I'm loving no this has been
a loving show so we'll end with some
love this is really interesting a new
study conducted by researchers in
Arkansas which is where I get most of my
studies from suggest that our pets might
have the same love hormone that humans
have it's called oxytocin and let's look
at some more info on findings for humans
oxytocin or the love hormone gets
released when you're cuddling or having
an intimate experience researchers
tested oxytocin levels in a dog and a
goat after they'd hung out separately
then they let the two animals hang out
together for 15 minutes after that they
checked again the dogs levels rose by 48
percent which is about how much of
humans would change in a similar
situation and I have an even bigger
number than that
the goats levels went up two hundred and
ten percent see no implying that the
goat was in love with the dog is this
what gay marriage was going to lead to
no yes bestiality and not lead to that
they've been doing this for thousands of
years loving sheep and goats in the
field though you know things get lonely
Stephen Stills put it best love the one
you're with cling and it wasn't bad
that's fine that was a cheap shot
Rick are you are you an animal guy - I
know Kelly's a big dog dog lady I'm a
big dog guy I'm a big animal rights
person yes I am yeah so does this
surprise you guy says as animal people I
love my dog I am completely confident
that my dog loves me well considering
that we are evolved from these creatures
it doesn't surprise me that we have
similar hormones I mean if you if if you
believe in evolution it makes perfect
sense and yeah and I think they're
finding out more and more now that
animals have a real inner emotional life
I mean isn't there a chimpanzee suing
his owners right now permits like a
cover of Time magazine
yeah something crazy like it's yes next
week you can cover next week but they're
finding they're having this they have an
inner emotional life which you know
really then goes to the argument for we
should not be animal testing we
shouldn't ultimately be eating these
creatures and yet we involved with them
and I can't do it I hated pet stores you
see them as a tiny Niall thing and
they're their feet are on those little
bars on the bottom there and it's like
it's that same idea you're watching a
pace you're watching it go crazy like a
prison well yeah it is absolutely it but
my thing about this which is you know
science is finding out all sorts of
amazing things about the brain and the
body and it's it's basically you know
it's it's discovering you know why we
oxytocin why we connect why we you know
the god thing you know the parts of our
brain that has that in it and it all
gets down reduced to cells and chemicals
and everything which to me is depressing
I think right you know Shakespearean you
know sonnets and Baudelaire poetry I I
want to believe in that and I think
there's a way you know from you know
being Old Testament and then through
rational science important important but
I think you have to also give that there
is something else between us you know
yes it's oxytocin and and what else
though you know I think that's exactly
what I Circle ten times here so that
part that part that's between science
and the part of us that's very human
that wants to believe that love is in
some oxy toe
or some me DeLoreans if we were in Star
Wars or something you know like a ritual
aspect yeah I love comedy but comedy
isn't emitting some big hormones you
know it's I love it on a spiritual bond
because the spiritual bond is I have a
hunger for certain things in my heart
and this energy comes in and starts to
fill the cup up I respond to that and I
want I will feed back and to start the
loop going because it on an animal level
I want to be near it I want to feed from
it some more but on a healthy level
that's what all love is based on
recognizing something that made you feel
good that's a need field yeah and I
think exactly and I think it's it is
about creating meaning in your life yes
it can be this chemical thing but our
minds these amazing big frontal lobes
are the things that create meaning and
and that gives life its power and and
why we're here and why we stick around
you know so and science can't [ __ ] with
that you know I mean it is what we do
with it we've taken chemicals and made
meaning out of it I mean look how
amazing we are you know sure the goat no
dog I love each other but maybe they
don't have any meaning around it we we
would have a whole story around yeah
speaking of chemicals too so going from
from the chemicals to to our brains how
long until we put this in pill form
because now it seems to me if we can
isolate this thing if we're good at one
thing around here it's putting
everything in pill form and we'll have a
little oxytocin pill and you'll pop that
with a Viagra and there's your there's
your rom-com they never intended to fall
in love timing you know I think actually
if they could put it in a pill form it
could save us all because it is the
ultimate love child flower power moment
I mean it is that if everyone took
ecstasy at the same time on planet Earth
something might
really amazing how dust works with that
oxytocin powder yeah well guys this has
been a loving show as I fully expected
it to be yes any final thoughts on this
loving note be good to each other
pretty good be good to each other be
good to these two people especially on
the Twitter er their handles are right
down below and thanks for watching and
we'll do it again next week